vera bonjour alors que peut-on retenir
de la réunion au conseil des droits de
l'homme bonjour levier le pose en
biélorussie tourne à tirano ce cas a
appelé la communauté internationale à
réagir avec la plus grande fermeté face
à la situation dans son pays à
l'occasion d'un débat ici par l'union
européenne l'ex-candidate à la
présidentielle avait jugé en lituanie
s'est exprimé dans un message vidéo
devant le conseil des droits de l'homme
des nations unies
je vous propose d'écouter un extrait de
son intervention la situation en
biélorussie exige une attention
immédiate de la part de la communauté
internationale des manifestants
pacifiques sont illégalement détenus
frappée et violée nous la majorité
démocratique de biélorussie nous avons à
plusieurs reprises exprimé notre
attachement à l'état de droit aux
valeurs démocratiques et au dialogue
pacifique
l'intervention de ce tournoi qui
commence qu'elle n'est pas du goût des
représentants russes et biélorusses qui
ont jugé qu'il était contraire au
règlement du conseil des droits de
l'homme
écoutez je voudrais attirer votre
attention et l'attention de toutes les
personnes présentes ici brad cats
auraient sur le fait que le format des
débats urgents qui se déroule
aujourd'hui ne prévoit pas la
participation des noms représentant du
haut commissariat des nations unies aux
droits de l'homme
cher au commissaire adjoint des nations
unies aux droits de l'homme
or ni du rapporteur spécial ni de
personne d'autre
sauf les états cromer d'ascq aucune
manifestation ne s'est déroulé
conformément à la loi sur l'organisation
de rassemblements de masse en
l'occurrence nous ne parlons pas de
l'interdiction du droit de manifester
pacifiquement mais de la procédure de sa
mise en oeuvre
les participants violer la loi par
conséquent il ya eu des milliers
d'arrestations
en dépit des déclarations des opposants
au gouvernement
les manifestations de la période
ou 12 août n'était pas toujours
pacifiques s'illuminer tracks citoyens
le titre annonce qu'elle est attendu le
21 septembre à bruxelles ont rencontré
les ministres des affaires étrangères de
l'ue eux et se rendre ensuite au
parlement européen l'union européenne ne
reconnaît pas alexandre loukachenko
comme président de la biélorussie et se
prépare à imposer d'importantes
sanctions aux dirigeants du pays celles
ci seront discutées par les ministres
européens des affaires étrangères puis
soumises à leurs chefs d'état et de
gouvernement lors du sommet européen des
24 et 25 septembre
merci beaucoup verra pour toutes ces
précisions verhaeghe hoffman en direct
de moscou